Lake Titicaca is home to moveable
floating islands that were created by
humans and we're over 500 people still
reside today
living on not so solid ground isn't for
everyone but a small South American
tribe in Peru known as eros have created
and maintained this unique way of life
the community is made up of roughly 70
human-made islands and one large central
island which is the hub for the tribe
they use dried reeds that grow along the
banks of the lake and shape them into
floating platforms and boats these
platforms can be moved from the mainland
if required which was originally a
defense strategy to escape danger
the Reed's into woven densely to be
about 80 inches thick large logs are
attached through the reeds and anchored
to the river floor over time the reeds
tend to rot and so they are replaced
four times each year the community is
home to the new and old world the reeds
are used as medicine and the flowers
drunk as tea however the solar panels
are used to help run some electrical
appliances and the central island is
home to a radio station until the mid
80s the islands were located further out
in the lake and were inaccessible by
visitors however after a devastating
storm the tribe has moved closer to land
and started welcoming tourists to
experience their way of life
you
[Music]